look and look you're so [ __ ] lucky
most people that are watching right now
have to do it for a boss they don't know
the greatest thing that ever happened to
me is the memories of people and she's
with my dad you know like I you know
it's crazy that I get to have those
memories one day my dad's gonna be gone
and I'm gonna be so happy about those
hours I put in those war stories you
understand so my question is basically I
have grown up with some great just to
give you context great parents
immigrants from Mexico and they became
citizens my dad when he was like 20 and
my mom when she was younger and
basically they raised us there is me my
sister really well but I felt like from
my dad's side and he did a great job of
structuring stuff and making sure I have
a good work that they can stuff of God
but for my mom side I felt very like
like if life had to be a lot of fun all
the time and that created yakeen I can't
really hear you I can hear I'm listening
it's very interesting that he put an
emphasis that life has to be fun
my mom did yeah actually she put a big
emphasis that their life had like
basically that every moment I couldn't
be sad that stuff I'd be finding and we
never really complained in the house you
think that but what's happened is
there's been a and and I've kind of
gotten out of this cuz I started
watching a content a couple months ago
but basically I got to a point where my
dad took away my allowance and I felt
like I deserved it okay yeah you know
what I mean getting it I was like when
did this happen
this happened maybe year-and-a-half ago
maybe how old are you if not a year ago
I'm 18 don't ya and basically
wait it got me it got me feeling wearing
now I was like well you know I'm just
going to figure stuff out now just
whatever and my Lance wasn't that big or
anything but it just felt like there
maybe happened like two years ago I
don't know but um you thought that they
were taking advantage of you that you
entitled to it that there was some
[ __ ] yeah I felt a little bit like
like wow these are my they're my parents
like they should be hooking it up a
little bit you know what I mean and and
it was crazy because what what did he
say he said you're grown ask me now stop
no more allowance basically basically
this video and I like him even more now
no he's great he's a great dad but
there's a time there was a time when he
was the like what we call him and maoli
la película which basically means a bad
guy he's a bad guy one point because you
know with my mom it was all fun and
whatever and that's common yep yep and
but now man I respect him so much
because start watching content and
started started realizing that I was
entitled and I was like what the heck
because that was it wasn't only the
allowance thing but several several
other little stuff and he just it's
sorry to liberate me but now I'm at the
point where I'm starting to work for him
cuz you know school got shut down and
not stuff and also my schedule is pretty
loose because I'm a senior in high
school and so I go to school for like
the first half of the day and then I'll
go work for him the second half from
like 12 before what does he do where you
are an electrical company things an
electrician in now attrition for 28
years so that's where I'm going into and
but anyways to get to the actual
question I'm sorry no work consistently
like a 20 hour work week soon to be 40
after I graduated and sometimes I find
myself during the week like there's days
where I love it and I'm having a good
time in whatever and there's days that I
won't write and I kind of feel like I'd
rather stay
home and play on my drum set because
that's something that I realize that
kind of like to do you have time to do
you only and that's man this is what I
want to talk to you because I was like
man I just don't know I'm like you talk
about diving into your passions and
stuff but I'm like I want also provide a
support for a future family what you
know but then but then it's like you say
that not everyone's life is gonna be
like yours and that we can have the
work-life balance if we want it and so
oh so first of all back to like when I
think about ingredients like you have so
many good ingredients like I love your
perspective 4818 I like the
thoughtfulness I love that you're over
the hump on entitlement I am obsessed
with the admiration and respect you have
towards your parents you remind me a lot
of me at 18 right now because I just had
a lot of that I think the one thing that
I was able to do was I worked a lot more
than you did
and still thought I did have time to
look at my baseball cards play Genesis
like I think that my work ethic might
have been more on point than yours is to
be free no Evan trip taking hours of
work and in that 20 hours you're like
damn I wish I was on my drum set and
like [ __ ] you could be on your
juice hours and even soon to be 40 hours
I laughed in my head on some real [ __ ]
is it 40 like 40 years I was 85 90 like
real [ __ ] hours and yeah look if
you're gonna work 40 you have a ton of
[ __ ] time to [ __ ] bang on your
[ __ ] drums you know and try side
hustles and hang out with friends and
live your life sorties nothing mm-hmm
it's nothing and and and what I mean by
that is you're in a great spot because
you have this like if you're talking an
18 about future family you've got that
[ __ ] in your soul which loves like what
you say you have that immigrant
practicality ya mean you're sold mostly
teen year-olds don't think about
providing for a future family so I'm
glad
in that practical place a bro on some
real [ __ ] forties nothing like yeah
Woody's nothing like III don't even know
how to explain it to you like I feel
like you have an ability to eat like
have some grit and eat some crow and pay
your dues yeah I've got good news for
you if it's really 40 you got off easy
family this second-generation like that
[ __ ] usually looks more like 67 82 like
if you're a great have tons of time
between 18 and 32 put in to your side
hustle of starting a YouTube channel
around drums to hang out to like I mean
[ __ ] 40 are you [ __ ] kidding me you
[ __ ] hit the lottery if it's 40 my
Friday Saturday my Thursday Friday and
Saturday of every summer day and since I
was 14 was forty seven to eight he had
13 hours times three like [ __ ] 40
you're [ __ ] set I'm real happy for you
because I think you're gonna be able to
check every box you're gonna be able to
help the family business
help yourself make some money but you
still have a hundred [ __ ] hours in a
week to [ __ ] sleep spend time with
friends and do your side hustle you're
fortunate now here's here's what I don't
want no cabin and it's like right now I
feel good and I have that drive but what
do I do when tomorrow I feel that like
like man that was great with Gary
yesterday right now you know we're back
to it and it's like cool and then and
then the next week slowly progresses
down high right now tomorrow you go hard
but then in two weeks you're back to
that place with two hours into the day
of electronically like [ __ ] I wish it so
listen this is what being a man and this
is what being an operator in life is
about learning how to get comfortable
with the uncomfortable is there you know
what I mean brother yeah we're gonna get
comfortable with the uncomfortable you
said learning to like well
in that zone at 11 a.m. in you know on
July 19th when you're like you're like
[ __ ] man I wish I was home playing drums
or I wish I was with my boy Salvatore
right now learning to get over that hump
is is very required right like that
isn't people are you know we are so
lucky we're so lucky that a lot of
people don't want to get a relationship
with being uncomfortable they just want
everything to be awesome is like it's
it's such macro entitlement as if
everyone's life should always be awesome
at all times I don't this is you know
don't create this narrative in your mind
of blaming your mom that everything has
to be happy is why you're incapable yeah
that's not your mom trying to make
positives out of negatives that's you
our [ __ ] so lucky that you had such
great parents that provide a dream that
you are not in a place yet where you're
like you're starting this incredible
process of getting out of entitlement
and I'm proud of you mm-hmm so now what
you need to do is kinda like working out
it's like kind of that extra 10 pounds
on the wheel this summer I'll get those
Reds get those reps that's exactly right
man I love that you understand like like
every time you read 11:30 in the morning
and somebody yells at you at the job and
you like [ __ ] man I could just be home
playing xbox every time you do that you
go into my [ __ ] parents immigrated to
America when they were my age
they were [ __ ] scared shitless of
making it in America they didn't have a
[ __ ] pot to piss in and I'm sitting
here complaining about a [ __ ] family
business that my dad create on his
[ __ ] back that I can go to gratitude
go to gratitude mm-hmm I just gotta
train it because because because the
main thing that was confusing me is I
was like I don't know like cuz you talk
about you know if you don't like going
or whatever then you shouldn't be doing
that but the thing was that I was doing
it something that I was liking it
sometimes they're not like another time
so that I was like you know what what's
to do here but you just man you hit me
with the unmarked yeah so real because
what's what's funny about that it's like
look unhappiness is not is is
something people should do but to your
point and this is why I love doing QA
when I say don't do something that you
don't loved I don't mean don't do
something you don't love for an hour
I mean don't let that be your 80 year
career yeah like that's real to me I
also say eat [ __ ] and like I believe in
eating [ __ ] like we just talked about it
in detail here 11:30 July 19th
you know Miguel on the job yells at you
and says that kid you [ __ ] idiot you
know like yeah yeah like that's the
moment you take a step back and you
think about this conversation and you're
like right when my dad was my age when
your dad was 18 17 or 18 or 17 I'm 18
when the dad was 18 tell me exactly what
he was doing if you know he was hustling
doing he was he was installing like
video game machines in Mexican what's it
called like not really bars but more
just like kind of convenience stores he
would go into I'll tell you sir real
quick he would go into the store and
told the the owners be like hey you mind
if I only sell these things for you here
and there but no I don't want any I
don't want any little toys or anything
and then he back here let me leave him
here for a day and then I'll come back
tomorrow and pick him up and if you
still don't want him you know and then
basically he would leave him there
a bunch of kids would come play on them
and buy stuff from the store and then
the store owner should be like oh [ __ ]
okay I won yep bro your dad was grinding
mmm your dad didn't love installing
[ __ ] video games and [ __ ] creams
and [ __ ] you know but like drunk you
have your whole life in front of you you
you absolutely need to build a relation
on was kept under 30 in America yeah he
needs to find a relationship with
adversity and getting comfortable with
eating [ __ ] and I think it'd be a great
summer for you to like learn that and
you know 40 thing is huge to me I'm so
I'm bro when I wouldn't explain to you
how lucky I think you are Ford the whole
[ __ ] rest of the week
90% if it's really 40 is it gonna be
really 40 which is great yeah he said 40
to 50 he said 40 or 50 if you wanted to
want an bro listen man let me tell you
something I thought I was the hardest
working person I knew when I was 28
years old running wine library [ __ ]
worked all day you know 8 a.m. to [ __ ]
8 p.m. every day that was soft compared
to Who I am now at 44 I go harder
stronger smarter this is about [ __ ]
reps and gaining muscles right your you
got your stocky dude I'm looking at you
right now you know that if you worked
out like a [ __ ] maniac for a year
eight right lifted weights you'd be a
[ __ ] monster cuz you've got that
build you know that I had mentally I had
that [ __ ] built mentally but it was
some [ __ ] reps for you that may be
[ __ ] completely unstoppable look at
this like you're going into training
you're going into training forty hours a
day to [ __ ] put calluses on your
[ __ ] hands [ __ ] crate thickness to
your skin to your [ __ ] dome
you're crazy go understand this is
you're going to training yes you need to
be like Rocky and [ __ ] rocky this is
about going in the snow like go into
this like holy [ __ ] I'm so lucky that I
get to go into training I'm gonna get
paid to try [ __ ] trained how to be a
[ __ ] mental assassin for the rest of
my life your watch yeah that's so really
yeah bro and you get to do with your dad
[ __ ] look you're so [ __ ] lucky
most people that are watching right now
have to do it for a boss they don't know
the greatest thing that ever happened to
me is the memories of beaches with my
dad you know like I you know it's crazy
that I get to have those memories
one day my dad's gonna be gone and I'm
gonna be so happy about those hours I
put in those war stories you understand
yeah I'm crying because I'm happy
because I'm this is I was on the fence
and I didn't want to leave because I
liked the electrical but I didn't want
to leave to try to get a job in in
drumming right because I was like I like
both I like working with my dad and so
this
this was really the unlock for me you
know that's why that's what I'm feelin a
man hours a week
drumming YouTube channel you can [ __ ]
lookin drumming come you can work at and
drumming company at night 4000 K create
gigs yeah [ __ ] you have so much time
and you're gonna gain a strength you're
gonna gain a strength yeah that's so
real of like just being good at being
uncomfortable in being like hey you know
this is kind of boring but I'm gonna get
through it because you know my family
built this and you know I'm so grateful
for the opportunity to even have that
because a lot of people my age coming
out of high school don't know what they
want to do don't have a job right and
you're gonna you're gonna learn a skill
you're gonna learn how to interact with
grown-ass men learn how to interact with
customers that are upset you're gonna
watch your dad versity you're gonna
learn you're getting an education a
training and you're gonna get paid you
should be paying your dad yeah oh man
Oh grateful that I decided that when I
was I realized that 22 that I had it and
I decided instead of go and build
something for myself because I could I
knew the Internet
I knew the [ __ ] in I knew the hustle I
[ __ ] knew it I was making $500 $1,000
when I was 13 I was 22 I was a grown-ass
man I didn't need to go into my dad's
business for me I needed to go into my
dad's business for me emotional I wanted
to give back because I knew I could and
I knew I was gonna learn a lot of stuff
and I was gonna enjoy it and I was gonna
enjoy the memories and I was gonna put
my dad on and it's the best 12 years of
my career did it feel great to be 34 and
not own anything of a business world you
know no did it feel great to not have a
lot of money because in a family
business you really never pay yourself
that much you know if I was an executive
360 million I've been paid a million a
year but was you know but but those
memories with my dad and doing something
that giving back to my parents who came
to this country with nothing and
the foundation that I stand on that's
something I'll never regret and you're
gonna have that opportunity
I [ __ ] only did 40 hours a week I
would probably started a Facebook card
starting lineups eBay flipping business
on the side too and gotten doubled you
know like happy so like yeah you really
have a good bro and it's so crazy that
you say that because of the fact that
like nearly only like a week and a half
ago I told my mom and I just talked with
her and I was like man I'm so grateful
for you guys because it's cuz I just got
I just felt this gratitude wave of like
man so right hope I just didn't know how
to apply it to the work thing because I
was I was confused on like whether or
not you know but man it's it's it's it's
all about the perspective of like man
when I'm older I'm gonna be able to look
back and say I got to work with my dad I
got to do the 40 hours like you said and
I can still do my other stuff and let me
see you could go 80 hours for seven
years and [ __ ] be 25 and young as [ __ ]
I'd put both my arms off right now to be
25 you know 90 hours a week do no drums
and bounce out of there as a [ __ ]
child still a child
mm-hmm you have you have everything you
have your perspective and and maturity
at 18 any of your whole life in front of
you you got a hundred more years of life
you're gonna look for a hundred more
years bro oh it's a real [ __ ] you're a
part of that lucky generation you're
gonna live to 180 no I believe that I
can see that
it's at least a hundred at least a
hundred a hundred eighteen you gonna
live a hundred more listening you will
never ever ever regret working 40 to 50
hours a week with your dad for the next
for a long period of time I promise you
that I rarely be that I'm rarely that
definitive but I've spent enough time
with you right now to know that to be
true you've got too much of that soul
and gratitude towards your parents any
kid who's watching right now
who is grateful and loves her parents
for what they did for them should go
into the family business because even if
it's a
you'll always be happy that you paid
back a little bit to the thing that put
you on
[Music]